It means that there's only one x-intercept. To see this in action, let's take a
look at the graph of the problem that we were looking at on the last quiz. So,
here's the graph of y equals 4x squared plus 4x plus 1. We found before that the
root of this was negative 1 half. And we can see that the x -intercept is at
negative 1 half, 0, just like we would expect. This parabola is special and that
instead of crossing the x-axis going down and then crossing again, in other
words, having 2 x-intercepts, it simply touches the x-axis at a single point,
which is its x-intercept. Another example of a parabola that does this is the
basic one, the parent graph, y equals x squared. You can imagine if we shifted
this over and made a little bit wider, we would get back to this graph.